citizens
of the reject Nation law-abiding
citizens of the reject Nation we're here
for more b99 we're gonna watch episodes
19 and perhaps 20 of season five are you
excited G yes I am
heck yeah leave a like on the video and
if you want to see the full reaction
come on over to patreon.comreal rejects
thanks to prepper for cutting these down
let's do this thing
Here Comes The Bachelor all dressed in
my nice jacket I only wear for special
events ah you're already on fire you're
on fire
this is the elite party Squad I want you
guys to think of me as one of the boys
so tonight I'll be swapping out my
captain's hat for my
Kangol hat
and go ahead I will definitely call you
Raymond Raymond of the cankle heads
ribbon of the Kingo hat time to party
yes
there it is batch boys isn't bad Raymond
in the Kangol hat that's bat street boys
I'm so excited for tonight thank you to
my best friend Kylie for organizing this
thank you for coming ladies and
gentlemen I like how Amy has one friend
outside of the precinct and my gift to
you is a cray cray night a funky fun I
fear I've already made the biggest
mistake in my life just wait till four
drink Amy shows up I thought we'd start
by discussing the etymology of the word
Bachelorette
or we could just play Never Have I Ever
maybe later also amps definitely
Beatrice looks great you guys know how
the game works right you drink if you
have done it okay bats boys bartender
now let's just grab a couple cabs what
do we have here do you ever notice how
blue this show looks
what just happened well that was
maybe we should see what's in it
scavenger hunt had sex back of a car
Thalia was a school bus we've done like
nine rounds of this and you haven't
drunk once maybe we should play
something else that actually gets you
drunk that's not true I've done stuff oh
my God you gotta go crazy today never
never I ever had a one night stand with
a guy from a band whoops yes I have whoa
dang watch out Madonna
I told Jake that you really liked that
band and he booked it for your wedding
as a surprise
yes surprise is it The Dan Band Jesus
wandering around aimlessly and we
haven't done one bachelor party thing
whatever you'd like I could share a lewd
story Kevin got me quite horny this
morning
I'm hungry no you're in luck the fanny
pack is filled with granola I don't want
Fanny granola I want steaks and whiskey
perhaps that's something a limo can
answer oh nice
it is to find you is that a Serbian
accent it is write that down for later
I'll see you in six hours six hours
oh ditch you
okay let's not get skirts just because
we've been doing this for 93 minutes and
we haven't figured out one damn clue
that's why I said oh it's got the whole
thing cracked all we have to do is
decipher this list of thousands of
random numbers I wonder one of them is
six nine pretty sure you mean 69 but I'm
so hungry I can't even appreciate
horndogram
horndog regmen in the Kangol hat Charles
would be so upset if we bailed or what
if Charles never knew we'd have to do
any of his dumb puzzles right instead we
can spend the next six hours eating and
drinking and talking about how we lost
our V cards nicely done that's real
slang there's a receipt for a party boat
rental and also a cake delivery to a doc
down at Bergen Beach that's been under
no circumstances will we do any bachelor
partying without Charles
oh jeez
Bachelor of Adventure Kylie you should
talk less sorry I have to direct it
somewhere nice to meet you by the way
Charles already gave us a name that is
the only one we're gonna use
Jesus Jake oh I'm so scared the
kidnappers have to be tied up and where
are you guys I don't want to say in case
the kidnappers are listening smart
what's close
should we order another round
[Music]
what is his name
put some of my thoughts down just to let
them out so I don't explode no matter
how lame that dude's man purse is
she did it with one of the Workaholics
how long were you with crying wedding
band man bun not that long I doubt he
even remembers me Amy Santiago ladies
and gentlemen
my life is
[Laughter]
we dated for three months that is not a
one night Charles has to think we're
totally sober and we solved his puzzle
I've seen you do enough of these hair
brain schemes in order to play along if
Charles asks what's wrong I'll just put
on a question
nothing they're gonna fall in the water
aren't they
oh yeah we're nailing this hello
Charles
surprise welcome to the party pal oh
that's actually awesome we get to the
best part steaks and shots
oh no what does that mean
oh you guys don't mess this up you guys
don't mess this up he was everything I
thought he'd be never before has a
person so perfectly met my expectations
I know Reginald Vel Johnson the best
Reginald Vel Johnson from
Sergeant Powell was a part of my oh no I
have one more surprise for you if I
could have your eyes ears and emotional
cores
I'd like
Knight had to be the biggest most
special bachelor party ever my friend
our new ordinary man in fact you are 24
Karat hey the dye hair photo 24 carat
gold is that a phrase I say no like the
coins from the hunt yes of course from
those now okay please present your gold
coin no here's the deal Terry's coin
fell out of his pocket and we lost it we
just didn't have the heart to tell you
oh no it costs 800 all right Terry will
pay me back later
oh geez I hate mine you hate your coin
yes I thought it was chocolate but you
hate chocolate it has too much taste you
guys didn't do the scavenger hunt can
you call yourselves The Bachelor
actually we call ourselves the steak
studs what are you doing talk to you
about a gig you have coming up Jake
Peralta booked it yeah you're winning if
you knew that then why did you take it I
wrote you a love song I'm gonna sing it
and I'm gonna win you back then we're
gonna be on the Today Show
tell him something came up and you have
to cancel the gig not happening I'm
gonna get on that stage and I'm gonna
play Amy come back fine maybe come back
I'm canceling your band that'll just
cost you fifteen thousand dollars well
when I heard it was your wedding I knew
your fiance would cancel when he found
out about us he didn't read the terms
the t's and C's we shouldn't have lied
to you but all of this the puzzle it's
what you wanted not me just wanted to
hang out with my friends don't let me
stop hang out with your friends all you
want because I'm leaving Charles yeah
coins he hit all over the city they were
so expensive also why does he keep
saying I'm 24 karat gold no idea zero
sense we'll have to figure it out later
in the meantime we gotta find those I'm
sure if you find it you'll know why all
we have to do is solve the entire six
hour scavenger hunt immediately toss me
that Sextant guys we can do this we're
way too drunk
be someone that knows where those coins
are right Charles
he's probably digging up the gold coins
but who would know where the gold coins
are Charles knows where they are but
where is he no wait a second we're super
drunk and we're in a loop we need to
find someone who isn't Charles Reginald
Vale Johnson
yes steal the contract and destroy it
destroy a legal document I can't do that
you're right I'm a boring square who's
never actually had a crazy well you're
gonna have a fun bachelorette party
tonight
only control so much
she's got ta explode
I'm just lying record executive at
executive records lucious lying I've
heard that name anyway I love you I love
you family matters Carl Winslow made me
want to become a cop come on Terry you
already have like six other reasons you
became a cop this is not your moment and
for the record
you're gonna tell us where those coins
are hidden or you're going to regret it
stay here all night
I'll tell you where he is yes thank you
so much also we're gonna need you to
take us there because we're all too
drunk to drive take a cap I'm already
represented by my mom God you're a turd
well this turd is your best friend's
Future Husband hey wait no doink
[Music]
drunk Amy go
that's gonna cost you fifteen thousand
dollars to
I've never loved you and that your whole
family is a bunch of friggins
[Music]
that looks
never have I ever broken his heart hired
him to play at my weddings you could
have a great aneurysmen especially after
midnight so I can now say whatever I
want tonight
was awesome and I loved hanging out with
you dorks
oh wow that is sweet Sheena dork is
actually a Celtic word meaning lungfish
capturing so hard this is where he's
coming to wait for you like that
Hitchcock Skully actually came in handy
I'm the one who should apologize I
overdid it tonight I hope things are
gonna change between us I'm getting
married I mean didn't you make me less
of a priority when you and Genevieve got
together yes
you made an enemy for life and I'm
telling Bruce Willis you suck it's good
but it's important to be made up my best
friend
to Jake and Amy
[Applause]
to Jake and Amy nice he left me a very
long message with a lot of details oh no
I'm just kidding I'll never bring it up
again thank you you're the sweetest oh I
love you I love you too turtlebug oh uh
do I still need to be here yes Reginald
we're all toasted and we need rides home
[Laughter]
oh it's fun when best men throw the
groom a bachelor party
that's right isn't it it's definitely
fun when they decide everything you
ought to do and it's not up to you a way
to justify someone not throwing we
should watch it I'm not justifying
anything I'm accepting the fact that we
did not plan a very good bachelor party
for you because if you don't plan a
bachelor party at all
play the next episode John I am not a
good person two best men did nothing
show me going is the name of the episode
23 Jake hurry up starving sorry sorry
sorry I just I just need to grab my wall
wow whoa Willy Wonka Paddington
three kids in a trench coat
fine I was trying
excellent excellent cold open okay
before we get going Sergeant Jefferson
suggested that it would improve morale
if we started the meeting with some
consensual non-work job exactly jabber
it's going to go well it's just a
regular morning for me woke up again
simply unavail we have a meeting at a
new multi-agency multi-state task force
it's a double multi it's a multi multi
you're better everything than I do
they're taking down a street racing gang
that's been using souped-up cars to
transport drugs across state lines it's
a real life Fast and the Furious movie
they glorify family and loyalty big hard
boobs on both men and women guess who's
heading up the task force plus they work
for the government I heard he diffused a
bomb with his teeth because his hands
were tighter I heard he bangs constantly
I know how competitive these task forces
can be especially this one because
Boomers come on Hitchcock Mel Gibson
is broken I think Scully did it he says
he
says he has his bathroom but who else
would leave a whole rotisserie chicken
in there I'm glad it's broken because
it's nice to see
now get in that stall and kill it in
there what sorry I'm a manager now so
I'm trying to be more motivational oh so
it's totally cool for detectives to come
down here oh no yeah that there's always
been tension between uniformed officers
and detectives but Rosa is one of the
good guys I'm sure she knows her name
you clearly just texted her the answer
no she didn't Alvarado
Tony you were still one of them we all
know now I'm caught in a turf war
between my new Squad and my old Squad I
know this is a big deal for you as a
manager but I gotta pee real bad right
right I believe in you woof weird I've
never heard anyone call you that well
they will soon the point is I'm
basically a young Boomer Maxwell are you
guys in here Boomer's not running
special unit anymore he shattered both
his legs jumping off the Chrysler
Building
also still cool he's going to be an iron
side wait if Boomer's not doing it who's
running the task force detective Brett
Booth from 6-3 that was your word we
were in the academy together during a
training exercise I shot him with a
rubber bullet wow goggles and hit him in
the eye it kind of messed up his depth
perception oh but that was a long time
ago I'm sure he's totally fine now it's
forgotten all about it oh well if it
isn't Jake
again
you're gonna regret this Peralta oh
[Music]
how did he get this for letting us in
his task force just because you blinded
him in one eye another one works just
fine no I mean the water cooler thing
was pretty you need an eye patch man all
we have to do is solve it before Booth
is done with his interviews in two days
that's impossible you know hate the word
impossible unless it's immediate
followed by the words go stand protocol
what's going on that's real whoa
multiple casualties ESU is on Route and
nearby officers are responding to the
scene right now
what the hell this is really real
what are they saying show me going in
their badge number they're telling
dispatch that they're close by and
they're responding oh oh no what
was it DS that's our badge number
Rose is there very special episode of
b99 I think it's gonna be the funniest
one
there's a lot of untapped comedy shooter
situation
to help Rosa ESU is on a scene and the
97 is locking down the area it's already
a zoo they wanted us to remain on alert
but not to respond yeah but that's just
a suggestion like how they tell you to
drink eight cups of water every month a
day every month Jake Sure I'm sure it
just blew in there on accident anyways
off to third grade I can't I dwell on
everything I'm a dweller I wake up every
morning I'm worrying about the zika
virus why is nobody talking about zika
anymore tell him you love him Jake
's well just ignore what's going on
together okay let's focus on the case
let's become Street racers
hey Charles
Speed Racer right this is exactly what
he wears and the best part is
yes just start the race well I wanted
this op to feel normal and races go wow
that's young oh yeah I had to use a
wiffle ball bat just to reach the gas
pedal and I never learned to use the
break things went South when I got
addicted to drugs after my best friend
died in an active shooter situation oh I
see what I did
Jeeps listen I was thinking Rosa seemed
pretty annoyed about the broken toilet
up here and since she's having a rough
day I thought it would be nice if we got
it fixed for her before she got back
because you were supposed to get it
fixed last week so oh god look I get
that you're worried about your own
mortality perhaps this fact will comfort
you as an NYPD officer you're more
likely to be crushed by scaffolding than
to die of a job oh God yeah city of
scaffolding no no Sergeant I was only
trying to point out that there are
millions of potential Ways to Die
I didn't want to do this but friend is a
cow and she's caught in the Brooklyn
Heights shooting right now so you think
of the first people that ever needed
toilet fix because a loved one's life
was in danger yes you're not that's a
grim commentary on the city we live in
refresh the news
refresh no news no news good news let's
clean up our desks right that's always
good for a distraction oh no Rosa gave
me this notepad
I remember I was all anyone got a
notepad it sounds like her so before you
can change your policy I'm gonna have to
ask you a few medical questions check
your vitals great just do it fast blood
pressure is going to be high okay then
let's start with your blood pressure you
know we can skip this part it's always
clocked in at 1 30 over 80. Terry's in
Tip Top shots fired jeez there were
shots fired I just got off the phone
there two offices down neither one of
them is Diaz what are we supposed to
wait until one is so we have to go up
there we have not a part of our Squad he
doesn't care about her look I know
you're concerned about Diaz I am
ordering you to stay on this Precinct
fine
oh yeah oh yeah okay I'm going up to the
scene of the shooting and I need your
help I can't sign tactical gear out of
the Armory without Holt's approval
that's our mission objective first
things first let's synchronize our
watches you just don't want this
episode's so blue 335 you too will cause
a distraction that draws hold into the
bullpen when Holt's not looking I'll
sneak into the office and answer the
phone when the Armory calls asking for
approval I'm captain Holt yeah I don't
know something feels awesome he sounds
too white here's how you do it yo what
up
so that plumber was useless but we are
too smart and capable people who can
Google it the internet will tell us what
to do she always does I'll just search
videos
oh rule 34 Amy you love rules
instructional video from a plumber on
how to fix an actual toilet
first thing we gotta do shut up
[Music]
they brought it back
that's why you watch these episodes back
to back that's right it's showtime what
oh I just said I have Showtime the cable
channel this must be nice
looking at each other I'm a little
worried that I'm gonna be able to do
this oh yes wow
and now they're doing the James Bond
torture
penis punch 69 is my band
[Music]
I'm sorry I thought you wanted to meet
baby Carol her surgery was such a
success Charles
we got something good bye what a weirdo
anyways thanks for the gun you just you
could just said yes please bless this
flesh oh man
oh it works
[Music]
oh no no that sounds fine that's totally
normal we picked it
get out of the way why are you
disobeying an order from the
commissioner I'm clearly the good guy
here all right if this was the movie no
one would be on your side you're
basically the guy in Ghostbusters who
lets all the Ghosts Out
they need someone to help them face
their fears and deal with the reality of
the situation okay great so why don't
you do it I try but it didn't work I'm
not particularly skilled at emotional
and I was hoping to actually do
something valuable like help Rosa
so you're gonna stand in my way or not
how are you gonna help Rosa yeah what
are you gonna do really do be
crazy sorry we should just give up this
was such a dumb idea yeah it would only
matter if we actually thought Rosa was
oh my God we should keep going right
definitely
also it's fun to watch you get destroyed
by a toilet yeah try working next to one
in a haunted house you know what I'm
trying to keep this line open so I don't
have time for your bull crap
I can't stay here all day I have other
things to do you a traveling nurse man
don't pick up me I'm sorry
it's been a tough guy read the room
grab a slice it's probably gonna be a
really long night none of you have eaten
anything Toronto where are you back so
soon because I wanted to do something
equipped them all with guns yes we're
all going down how do I deal with the
fact that every day I leave for work I
might not come home man I don't even
know Terry I don't have kids yet but I
know you love them I feel like that's
all you can really do right now that I'm
getting married I keep thinking of
something normalize that blood pressure
hey look at that 130 over 80. back to
normal I can get out of your hair now oh
nice tells you Andrew Terry's in Tip Top
thanks Jake
you know what would make a great movie
one where the hero sits with his friends
and they talk about their emotions I
know that you're just being nice right
now but that would be a terrible movie I
mean what would the poster be it would
be The Breakfast Club poster get
yourself
[Music]
still just going to voicemail
okay
I don't have the names of the injured
officers but if Diaz should be paralyzed
perhaps you'll be walking off the
elevator at any moment
doing stuff like that man I was just
making a copy downstairs yeah well next
time you think about what I don't know
okay Jake hey come from felt like
walking so I took the stairs also I
thought it'd be funny to mess with you
guys Rosa you know I hate pranks little
pranks I do I really do oh I'm feeling
into it are you sure because the journey
I went on today taught me that sometimes
it's best to talk let's just go get a
drink and sit in total silence perfect
first I gotta go to cam actually you
might want to check out the ladies room
up here
you made it sound like you fixed a
toilet yeah I thought maybe Amy would
have pulled something together in the
two minutes I stepped outside
yeah look what I stole from the Barnes
oh yeah
wait are you covered in toilet water yes
big time but this is happening oh fine
I kind of feel like I'm lurking Tina get
in here
yes they should have made this really
real and really harsh this is the
reality of the world you live in now on
Brooklyn nine I think six episodes of
her in a coma and then she just dies
yeah yeah yeah
and try and try and mix one wackier
subplot in for the B story every episode
while the main a plot is just everyone's
sort of holding hands and hoping yeah
they have a lot of missed opportunities
here
very interesting yeah it's a very
interesting choice I mean I I like what
they chose but yes I feel like there's a
lot heavier and more pointed you can go
it's weird I think just having the
toilet subplot is fun and it matches the
theme of like we got to do something for
Rosa we got to distract ourselves
but also I feel like you could have used
that time in a different way maybe
like what I don't know I mean like I'm
very I want to insult the writers while
the writers are striking John come on
never come on never you want to
criticize their hard work well it's
fascinating
and I really enjoyed that they went they
don't deserve it hey I should have
written this John is there what I'm
saying is I think computers are just
better at this stuff than people they
have way broader understanding of the
prospects of Life uh no I think it's I'm
torn I think it's really nice that they
did an episode that uh matches most
people's eye line when they hear about
an active shooter situation and God
forbid that somebody you love is
involved this is all you can do is sit
around and wonder uh and hope and wait
and kind of confront the idea or not and
I think that is kind of a clever and
sophisticated Choice there
um but I don't know I mean like I it
would have been way too much if they
just made it an action movie certainly
and uh had Jake run off and join the
fight I don't know I don't know if it
would have been
worth going into some more you know
harsh territory or not
I caught all that sure
yeah
good stuff John
uh sure yeah I could have done that
they could have done that I don't know
why did you think it was a mcpeck huh
why'd you think it was a mixed bag I
didn't say it was a mixed bag what's the
first thing you said
no I didn't oh
I never said it was a mixed bag
yeah so it's I don't know maybe maybe
I'm on correct I think you should play
the video back and you'll find out Greg
never said it was a mixed bag okay
in fact we have a recording here on the
computer yeah I know you said something
this is something to the effect of that
I said they should have killed her off
no that was it was not the joke it was
not the obvious joke and then the coma
and the six weeks and then she just dies
no it wasn't that part
I'm pretty sure that's all I said all
right well you know the the people can
catch us now although it is a mixed bag
say that
it's all right I still attest I did not
say all right that it's a mixed bag you
know what I'll I'll but I will say
because you're exactly the one who has
the photographic but I will say it's a
mixed bag
um okay well why don't you think now
that we've established finally that it
might have been I just wanted to be
technical about it sure of course
I think they were trying to preserve
comedy when this show has already done
the comedy just sort of felt uh
uh like
the same
the company lacked a Nuance approach
whereas before they've had more serious
episodes where they have still managed
to maintain the humor in ways that
really worked and here it still had that
like surreal Larger than Life outlandish
um
comedy bits that that actually felt like
it conflicted uh with the tone like it
actually undercuts some of the
seriousness
versus elevating or aiding in it they've
done serious episodes before where
they've maintained the comedy but I
didn't feel that way and here it would
feel uh jarringly different in certain
scenes sometimes though it still worked
for me sometimes it was still funny like
the the thing with the phone and and uh
when he's trying to get the gun
Hitchcock and Scully fighting each other
I thought was really funny yeah
sometimes it was still really funny and
I think the toilet thing was supposed to
represent you know in a situation that's
out of your control you try to control
try to channel your anxieties and pain
somewhere else so you're trying to
control the situation and I think that's
ultimately what they were attempting to
represent the the subject is so relevant
and so like this came out in 2018 but
you know for 2023 now we know that
active Shooters are a very serious
problem in this day and age very common
so it's a very it's very sensitive and
it's very serious it's I I think
honestly they probably should have just
leaned a little bit more serious instead
of having
instead of feeling the need to I guess I
felt like the Amy genus subplot
especially fell prey to like we need to
keep one of these really light and funny
even though like I agree that the point
is like yeah a situation you can control
and doing something nice to keep the
hope alive that the person will be back
if we stop doing this we kind of accept
that she's not coming back but it does
feel like when you cut back to that
especially from like a commercial Gap it
is like okay now we're back into sort of
zanier territory when I think they could
have given it some more of that tense
pathos kind of
I don't know it seemed like it became
more about them being upset at the task
rather than it revealing that oh we're
really just agitated about the situation
and maybe
maybe Rose's experience will factor into
later episodes and I get that you had to
keep her away so you're enhancing the
fear and the suspense and it's about the
worry that these that people are going
through you know which is more
identifiable I suppose for most people
because they've had a lot of people
who've died from shooting or experience
from shooters or you know had
the fear of the unknown of what might
happen to them so I get that I was
focused on them part of me does want to
see if this does factor in a Rose's
experience though moving forward it
might not yeah
surprises me sometimes when they do that
yeah it would make sense I mean it
seemed like at least just looking at her
performance it seemed like she brought
some of that like I believed her when
she's like I don't want to talk about it
um
and it fits the button of the episode
but yeah I I think it would be
interesting and worthwhile if they maybe
addressed it again and they've this
season been doing more of those
serialized beats yeah yeah so I would
hope that that happens somehow because
yeah that is kind of the ultimate thing
I'm like this episode did a lot of
things I really admire but especially
thinking back to some of like to the
Terry episode especially I feel like
that one managed to kind of transcend to
a place where you're like yeah this is a
very special episode of but it's also
got the charms they're just all kind of
tweaked and attenuated in in kind
whereas this one didn't feel quite as
like balanced yeah I feel like they
could have just started off with it and
yeah and then
and and then just have more of a focus
on it as opposed to like that the whole
storyline there of like Jake and uh oh
yeah the whole task force yeah
for Cameo supposed to set something up
or whatever
um yeah they're the whole other thing in
the Fast and Furious case they had the
funny cold open and I'm like you could
have canned all that and not that I
enjoyed all of it but yeah I think it
could have been excise and you could
have moved that to a different episode I
think you could have shortened it
because the point is probably like oh
this is a normal day and then this crazy
situation you know impinges on it but I
think you could have established that
way quicker but all that being said I
actually still enjoyed the episode wait
yeah no I'm glad they did it there's a
lot of things that I wish they could
have done
uh
which I know people love when you place
your own rewrite on something
but I I still really like the episode no
I'm not just saying that to say that it
was still very enjoyable
and and I appreciate the the attempt at
Nuance as well and some of those moments
yeah like when Rosa does return I
thought that was really sweet and tender
and it got they got in the heart feels
uh quite a bit there for me and uh the
first episode with the bachelor party I
like how it actually did escalate into
Amy getting to have that experience
where she did get to go against the ab
code of conduct uh the guest star was
funny and why does kids you know guys
yeah he was really really funny and
um the whole scavenger situation
Workaholics what is that guys the whole
scavenger hunt bit was great where uh
you got to see like a naughtier side of
Holt which was great yeah really Randy's
side of it yeah and Reginald Vale
Johnson Reginald Johnson I have that
cameo in there legendary actor Reginald
Johnson right really showed up
it's true he is known for those two
roles isn't he those two specific roles
probably like a hundred credits between
yeah yeah that you would he's probably
one of those actors who has like a
thousand credits but you only hear about
those two
um and yeah boy went all out on it
it's a fun episode
from a friend like that I know one of my
great all-time regrets in this life
it's okay
no don't worry about it when you guys
rather your family uh worked really hard
there
to make sure you were when you renew
your vows we're gonna come up and they
made sure to come up what you don't
realize is that the bachelor party is
all is still going and it's just a
10-year protracted augmented reality
when you guys will throw you all the
Bachelor of a newly made bachelor party
I love half of the kids yes just slicing
down the middle yeah King herod's style
you're gonna have it all good Rob Mia my
entire she's like a dementor yes and
then she'll take your half of the party
too yeah we throw you for becoming a
bachelor it'll be a bachelor party for
yeah
when you renew your vows sure we'll take
you laser tagging into mini golf and to
Chuck E cheese wow you guys really want
to throw a party
we don't
clearly don't know how to throw a party
but guys what would you have done for
Greg's bachelor party leave your best
itinerary below and uh put us to shame
and go do the same on the jabby coach
and uh hey do we have time for a shout
out or should we just get on out of here
got time for one shot time for one shout
out to five we normally do who is it
gonna be let's shout out I want to shout
Maria Hammond Maria Hammond go for it
someone was being mean to me on her
patreon and then
um I don't think Maria Hammond watches
the reactions too the that episode that
show sure
of Rick caught that comment oh and like
the fierce Warrior woman that she is I
saw it this morning like I haven't even
replied to the comment I mean I I've
acknowledged it in an upcoming video but
uh I just thought I'm already just like
immediately just goes the fact for
videos she ran in she ran in like this
yeah checked out the Reich here and ran
in Murray oh man I could really count
you know some strong women in my life
and Maria happens certainly wanted them
she just goes in there just a handles
business don't even need to ask uh in
fact I expected I expect it from you now
your Rosa Diaz you don't step in I'm
gonna I I blame you I go where the hell
are you Maria why weren't you there to
defend me what's your problem my honor
is here no I can't do it I'm too
sensitive
values yeah I so I appreciate you I
always whooping ass on behalf of real
Rejects
uh you're an absolute deer and maybe I
would have replied I just been so short
on time but I was fast so I'll pop up in
the Gmail like there she is my queen
right there so oh thank you Maria for
always being uh the
the the
matriarch of the reject Nation
and the heartthrob as well
talk to you later dear peace